muy bien hagamos un poco de práctica
estimando longitudes y el primer
ejercicio dice esta línea mide un metro
muy bien esta línea es precisamente de
un metro aproximadamente cuánto mide la
valla y nos dan tres opciones un metro
seis metros o catorce metros muy bien y
aquí tenemos la misma línea que teníamos
aquí arriba para darnos una referencia
entonces de inmediato podemos ver que la
valla es mucho más grande que un metro
verdad así que un metro no será pero
podemos más o menos copiar copiar más o
menos esta misma línea déjenme ver si lo
puedo hacer un poquito más ok
así tenemos ahí tres de esas líneas
podemos poner otra de esas líneas una
quinta de esas líneas y finalmente
podemos poner una sexta de esas líneas
así que tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
seis metros de longitud verdad y de
hecho 14 metros es algo muy exagerado
así que nuestra respuesta correcta sería
6 metros 6 metros es lo que mide esta
valla muy bien vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo vamos a hacer un ejemplo
distinto aquí tenemos digamos ag que
podría ser una flor verdad quizás sea un
girasol o algo así que tiene una altura
de 40 centímetros y lo que no sabemos es
cuánto mide de altura y esta otra
pequeña flor que tenemos a la derecha
muy bien así que si tenemos esta
referencia de que la flor grande mide 40
centímetros pues más o menos podríamos
estimar que está esta flor chiquita se
encuentra como a la mitad verdad más o
menos podemos ver de hecho lo voy a
poner como con líneas punteadas con
líneas punteadas para que sea para que
lo podamos distinguir podemos ver que la
altura a la que se encuentra la pequeña
flor la flor pequeña
20 centímetros verdad así que esta
altura de aquí es de 20 centímetros esto
es más esto es aproximado es una una
estimación verdad otra forma en la que
podemos ver es que por ejemplo si
tenemos esta altura esta altura es de 40
centímetros esto es de 40 centímetros
bueno pues más o menos por aquí estarán
los 10 centímetros por aquí estarán los
20 centímetros más o menos para esta
altura estarán los 30 centímetros y
hasta acá arriba estarán los 40
centímetros así que podemos ver que la
altura de la de la flor chiquita de la
flor pequeña está a la mitad de esta
altura de la flor grande que es en total
40 centímetros y como está la mitad
entonces tendríamos que mide 20
centímetros